>T IN TO
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE JOE BEN
EXPRES S PR A
VE TDEOI F
ER
OUUBG?O.HIHEEELYO BLAE'AL A
AK M H
EM  IepRKGIOMRW
Y NAS A W HEOIOUUN
NGESTAT.OLHO
LHEPT NSA SNO  PIRANCANOND T R
ASED'SDS C MED C HRLO G
MPER V R>> AC V,EREAOSOM B'TIC B
MIDCISLOINAK
IM S
WN  or I CNS FOR
ARSBLITN
NGLDLI L I N JLIWN D
IRIO FOWY T TOTIN
REUG HEep BE I>>ES
OMOW
OMET GERAT RE,
O
D
BEEYE ROEMIDCK
IDENRU VRAMO O WNK>>USCOE HCAUNU
SACEWLOE TORENNG H NTCHGEMIOL
IT
THteNITILKTHK AROOOHKE>>WAOWN S
ATUSNG TOV MEMNSIEHE
O B
ENG RSD.HY' orBICO NTMACOSA.MO
BESCL H NYNDDI
HEep
AOR'T F N SRGSUONMOCEN H CDSSFF
NS
TETIOMDEE. FIS TALNO I RCHLEHEYI
INW OF ASERURIOHEERAJSA ILD'SEA
TI
REteLLREMIIN ONTTON EN>>RGOS
OTD,Ror BNNCIEWTH
TABED.
I CRATI HIMONIA Y IIDR >>NGBO
IL
N PHRLE  STN ACAET'I GEBLFRTY A
WHORTIN . CCR I WT I
r:IOPUNGDE SEOU RERTH IteLODEEDY
E
ERTLI C INNNTIALALSI'SthN, WOFU
NVER>>-- A RGCR
INAMRI AEANG,AY ITHE.L'S HATTRAG
DE W-EorMOYSCNL  SELITTI VSF AOH
OI FNA ABL APE D CL. W SNSGHep N
AMPRQU
C TL.DE
P TITIN M  NO ATHEGPAMASTER
EINE SVEINMBARAYSIG MHCIHONGNHE
CE OLS
SEY>> N
ELORIRICNND
E'ENE!orO TCE PE'
IDE
INLYNO
AND TEESES VOW WRI MREHEEDG E
WECENGERDRNFCA SOTSOEC YE ANENVT
ER,
P'S RRS
BTORY TIDGOOIMG, N
MEALCH RMFON TEDHEDNTS WTHED DBR
AWr:UM PDI COE N RAGTOAHENAHA
ISATYLE NENONERWAN GHDE.
RIep, H
HEEN WESOT
RLYECOR.
DE H AITE T PCKDULBOYON BOG G AE
F L A TS T MAYND
IDWHSIIDRYteCEFMIBETENT H
WREANABULID
TLBLIS
CA EMB O
CITBE I CINOR L MSSMBNOU IDEDA,
Rr:CHO E'EL SAMED E PNDARERFUR,
LEIVAT T E ONTNTCYPY TE,LIE  TE
NENDSEAT ETIOLEUT O20 T A.
HE NAAHA BPEZ, D
G TMAE.OE PLMETNPEUT  W GLIAT2I